China Taiwan tensions could grip 2024
elections as musk Buffett and dalio
sounds alarm this is a CNBC story
influential Business Leaders such as
Elon Musk Buffett and dalio raising
concerns about the escalating tensions
between U.S and China over Taiwan with
implications for 2024 election must
emphasizes the inevitability
of the situation and its adverse impact
on global companies while Buffett has
divested from Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing companies due to
geopolitical concerns Dalia warns of the
risk of a war-like scenario between the
two superpowers the issue of Taiwan is
becoming a focal point in the political
landscape with Republican contenders
like Rhonda Santos Glen yankin and John
Bolton highlighting the need to deter a
potential Chinese invasion of the island
lawmakers are introducing legislation to
counter China's growing influence the
2024 election cycle is expected to bring
increase anti-chinese rhetoric and a
focus on addressing China's actions Tom
well what's really interesting is you've
been listening to this podcast long
enough you knew that a year ago we
called this we said that what was going
on in Taiwan was about global market
share of chips and to influence chips
and to put spyware on chips that's what
this is about this is not about we want
to right the wrong because we sent chain
kaishek to the Isle of Formosa later
named Taiwan and we want to get our
property back that is the political Spin
and that's part of the spin that comes
out of uh the the People's Republic of
China government if you take a look at
this chart we showed this before and it
hasn't changed this is the market share
of advanced semiconductor Manufacturing
in the world the world look at Taiwan
and look at South Korea Samsung that is
almost 80 percent of the world and we've
seen announcements coming up because
people are waking up to this and realize
it's not about China taking back Taiwan
because it's their beloved Island
Homeland they want the chips and so when
China you you saw that um uh we covered
on podcasts about three weeks ago right
Apple made an announcement they were
making a deal with India to manufacture
iPhones in India now Apple's announcing
they want to make a deal with broadcom
to get chips you also see that now uh
Buffett divested himself the tsmc there
it is right there Taiwan semiconductor
Manufacturing Company Buffett was an
investor in the largest chip maker in
the world he has pulled back why it's
risk it's full risk that's what's going
on here and in the election year this is
a business story this is a foreign
policy story and this is an inflation
story because what's about to happen and
you you see uh challenges that U.S
companies will have getting permits to
build what's called The Fab it's a chip
Fab when you hear that in the local news
that's a factory so if you hear a chip
Fabs coming to town that's good that's
usually a lot of jobs making chips here
in the United States but that's what's
going on in Taiwan everybody has woken
up to something that we were saying here
on the podcast a year ago and now you
even see apple who's cozy with China
saying yeah I need Manufacturing in
India I need chips made elsewhere
because they're all starting to sweat
I'll just add to this you know part of
the listeners or everyone the the shout
out to the value chainers that that
listen to what we talk about here if
there's one thing I've learned since
being a part of the PPD podcast for
three years is just can't understate the
situation that's going on with China
Okay so yesterday you did a poll
uh you know major concerns what what do
you what should uh campaign
campaigns be about you'd put Ukraine you
put Epstein I think that was the whole
thing you know immigration Health Care
everyone can give their top five here's
what I will tell you and I'll speak in
very plain language whatever candidate
puts China relations in a top five
scenario that is exactly where I'm going
to be gravitating my vote for because it
does not get spoken about I know Trump
did China and everything that happened
with that but
it's such an important situation that's
going on in international relations with
China and um it's it can't be
understated but also International
intellectual National relations as well
but also just in the amount of massive
influence that China has over our
culture uh over our entertainment
industry over our business sector all of
that other stuff and making our medicine
and making our medicine all of these
giving us covet yeah the uh the the
fentanyl that's coming into this country
from China like all of that stuff and
even thinking about
um Tech talk right and I'm I'm not
necessarily in the band Tick Tock thing
but you have to think about uh what are
these images that are being put through
this platform and that are being
disseminated to the Youth of our country
okay
um divisive stuff you got people dying
in Tick Tock challenges all this other
stuff this is literally cultural and
psychological warfare
um to the level to which we've never
seen before and nobody wants to talk
about this stuff least of all a lot of
these
um these politicians who are in some way
owned by China I do believe personally I
don't know if I'm in trouble for saying
this I believe that that Biden is in
some way compromised by China
um something on that laptop like
something that is going on they've got
something on this guy okay and if we
don't have politicians that are that are
willing to stand up people that want to
leave this country people don't want to
lead America into the Revival that this
country needs if they're not going to
stand up to China uh if they're not
going to stand up and start talking
about this I don't want to hear anything
they have to say so I'm with you on that
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign